hello everybody my name is markiplier
and a lot of you have been begging me to
play more SCP containment breach because
there was a point zero one update and
there was like a new model added in the
new beginning that I've already seen and
everything I've already seen and I know
I didn't want to play it because there
wasn't enough content to warrant coming
back but I said you know what maybe I
will maybe I'll give it a try so here it
is version six point six my little
foundation containment is Magic love
tolerate friendship I'm gonna make sure
my settings are still correct yeah
everything's okay alright let's see
market pony that's it that's a good one
let's enable the intro sequence to
[Music]
[Applause]
okay here we go
how the hell is this oh no this is the
same what we got here
let's see thank you for playing our mob
blah blah blah if you're not a Brooke I
am NOT a brony
I'm gonna have a bad time hi well you're
not a pony so where are you
just follow me we're authorized to kill
any disobedient Tessa yeah screw you
let's go no I refuse what are you gonna
do about it what what Oh mom ago and you
told me to get back there I here we go
come on follow me everybody well hello
what done I didn't seem right
hmm something strange going on around
here
see I don't know which one that is
hello aren't you two just adorable
Otis okay it's okay okay
why are sir confetti and party horns on
the ground Oh thank-you pie could have
guessed that one I mean it
doors aren't responding to any of our
attempts to close it so please maintain
a large distance of Pinkie Pie
oh no they're not dead there seem to be
just fine
how are they mating in there
all right that's weird
okay let's go I guess got diabolical and
I said f5 yeah that's right okay all
right sounds good to me
so it's s CP 173 is now Pinkie Pie once
again I must reiterate I'm not a brony
in any way so I don't know half of the
half of the ponies that are in here all
I know is that this constantly made fun
of a lot so like I don't got anything
wrong with bronies don't get me wrong
it's just I am NOT one of them and this
is just a mod I saw what hi are you the
duck you're the little rubber duckie
he's supposed to be little rubber duckie
oh look at you go okay let's try this
right I heard I hear you I hear you you
big stone pony concrete Pony hi
aren't you adorable why are you just
accusing I ever saw whoa
oh is that ah I know you're still
dangerous okay I heard like some guy
crying in the background anata no oh
what is that what is this one what is
this one gonna be okay it's the same so
far what done is that a guy with like a
pony mask on and he's a crying oh that
would be so hilarious
oh I would be so funny Hagen I got a I
got a see the face I got to see the face
hey buddy I saw enough
oh that's horrific I'm bound
I am lip ah he'll never get me in here
I'll be safe in here
I noticed that the music is
that's still scary that's so scary [ __ ]
yeah holy balls
oh that's hilarious though they like
that mm okay getting away from here I
didn't know don't spin me around to look
at it I'm not gonna look at it that is
so weird oh man this whole mod is just
creepy
why is my vision keep getting spun
random places
[Music]
hello dead guy you're new
no but ghost or was that the but ghost I
think that was the but ghost - replaced
sound yep no more but ghosts now is it
creepy creepy creepy creepy creepy
bronies and boom Pony vans oh man
like I said I need to reiterate even if
I make fun of them for this I got
nothing wrong with bronies you do what
you want to do
I hear ya Pinkie Pie think this with
your pinkie pie and Billy I guess y'all
weird hello oh you're wearing where are
you you at the end of this hallway ah
it's you adorable not really at all even
a little bit not even a little bit what
kill me
what can't me think about all time what
I fell through the floor oh man okay all
right I think I felt through the floor
which means my safe is now borked so I
got to try this gun mark a pony markup
Poh and why no market market brownie I'm
being welcomed among your ranks I guess
ha ha ha ed Frankie that is weird
I don't like it it's unnatural unnatural
[Music]
kind of like the music though has
sounded an evolution of like the My
Little Pony theme song or something or
is that just custom music cuz if that is
just custom easy I like it alright here
we go
trying this again not trying to get food
you heard me foods I don't want to be
food ok let's go
starting here again I do not like
starting with this one
ha ha and like I said before that is the
slender music isn't it I'm pretty pretty
sure I'm like almost 100% on that one
that is slender music wait is this the
same seed it might be the same seed hang
on let me check
no it's not wait yes it is that is it as
it's the same thing
fede need shut up I don't care about
your ponies
I don't want ponies no ponies please
note that is not fair [ __ ] Oh
embracing them with so much pressure
that their neck snaps oh so she's just
trying to give me a hug that's all
that's okay I need to figure out how to
get away from this one I just need to go
back oh not you again
yeah yeah everywhere Oh
friendship I didn't even grab the
keycard last time so I might as well
have died thank you fine yeah you're
back there I know ya is hi bye okay so I
saw ya does that mean you're gonna come
over this why
maybe I don't know I don't know
no no let's go come on pinkie pie forgot
your name a piggy bye
come on what you got we got breath
boys you gotta breath still there good I
was hoping you're still there need to
get quickly to this okay
I should be okay right okay yes made it
my super Pro SCP skills have finally
kicked in a blunder when they were duh
job still grow up what up what is this
wait isn't this the doo doo doo bird
your walkie
yeah well this does not look like a pony
and I know I've seen quite a few ponies
in my time and take it
yep this is the thingy hello Oh first
day man they really went far on this
unchanging to sing okay so this has got
to be a slow process of upgrading not
card here just set on fine cuz very fine
will destroy Church honk
shapow got it arrived once more into the
breach where were the shot and shell
blah blah blah that'll do
all that jazz far on this a Tennyson I
don't know
bar shoot shot and shell road the three
hundred blah blah blah Alfred Lord
Tennyson Manson or something like that I
don't know what I'm talking about I
don't know I don't know anything I'm
just an idiot video game player who's
playing uh on my little pony mod of a
scary game and is somehow still scared
by it
what's wrong with me hey Rolly man what
wrong with me
it's a weird all right level five should
be more than enough got it let me just
upgrade my mask and then I will be good
am i navigator yeah they're fine doors
slamming oh yeah come on come on borrow
my ride I ain't got a lot of tennis
ponies on my ass and you don't want
ponies on your ass
good blue blue blue got it got it got
super gas masks ultimate navigator and
dig near me nope I'm clear and free like
a summer breeze alright moving forward
got my super gear miss shaving and
inconspicuous location Blake oh hey
Gabbar you down there you down that big
about I don't want to go that way unless
I have to I guess
ah I'm making good progress so far yeah
yeah how do you still still know if I
need a battery no nothing so far
I'm gonna forget to use that in
different rooms so oh not know of these
I'll go the other way oh no I will not
go the other way I'll go this way
thank you very much no thank you okay
there's nothing in there that I see so
let's go infinite sprint yeah got it
nailed it I'm so great hey blink after I
saved oh come on not this up pass I'm
gonna bad actually you know what I don't
have a lot of time and the last thing I
want to do is I want to see what 106 is
like so let's go in to the tunnel and
meet our good buddy radical Larry or
whatever his pony equivalent is come on
buddy
what guys [ __ ] you kidding me that ball
was Ricky fine down there
why why why does that happen why is that
be that way that's not supposed to
happen
you you and your friend thank you
like a trance I can infinitely sprint
backwards good god you son of a [ __ ]
hi oh let me out let me out let me out
let me out where's the button where's it
on this way okay oh no he comes oh I
know I can't see anything off crap
what okay let me get a good look at ya
before you come not fun it's not fair
stop her nothing princess molestia
secret porn stash what oh man
princess molestia molest you
oh god damn I don't know whether to
laugh or just cry in a corner like I was
doing there's got to be a way to get
around her I know there is I know there
is I just gotta find it so go I'm
assuming pinkie pie's or her right yeah
let's get my gas mask on again ah where
are you where are you okay
I like there was something standing in
my way that I couldn't get through okay
I'll go this way
let's see you this way ghosts are bad
I'm sprinting FNLA away from you cuz I'm
just that much of a badass it was this
door here but there doesn't seem to be a
button ah get it get it it seems to be
locked
oh hi Oh with you Jesus what's going on
with your face hang on I got it
what is whoa whoa whoa
all right get me too much love and
caring all right let's see what's going
on in I don't know what that was
oh it's all Technicolor rainbow II or
prismatic more accurate okay so let's
just save in here moving forward oh my
whoa is that oh goodness golly that was
startling oh lordy Lou ha ha ha I can
laugh at you too ha ha wait a minute
this doesn't look familiar
wait what is this what is this I'll
remember this at all was this added this
might have been added what are they
supposed to be
oh no but I'm getting at here it's
freaky weird yeah I've never seen this
before
what is this someone in the comments
tell me what SCP that's supposed to be
or what that's supposed to be in the
radical Ares dimension because I don't
remember seeing that ever
everything's going topsy-turvy on me can
I please get some calibration on that
yeah everything seems to be a little
different I'm not being ported around
I'm they're actually stuff here well
kind of I guess I mean stuff that I
don't want hi hey buddy is that you on
your throne cuz it's your dimension hi
okay I'm leaving I'm leaving as slowly
as possible because I can't move more
than half a mile per day okay
need to see rest of area I am kind of
surprised usually when I get to this
area kind of ports me around but it did
not unless I just somehow pick the
magical door that I've never managed to
pick before that actually takes me to
this interesting area and what is this a
bridge that drops off into nothingness
nothing is empty like the point that
feels my soul oh okay yeah was okay
let's go go oh good I'm okay okay so I
just gonna wait oh maybe it's not gonna
come ah now kill me maybe it's not gonna
oh yeah it did okay I don't know how to
get through there what I can only go two
miles an hour day here I don't know love
tolerate friendship okay let's go down
another door I've all I'm I'm gonna I'm
gonna give us a good look I'm not just
gonna end this short of war Hey
oh hey there hey there buddy friend Oh
war I'm out already no wicked hey I'm
out already that's so weird wait the
cards gone saw him back to where I was
yeah I'm back I'm back where I was
all right that's good enough for now I
guess let's just pause it for here um if
you guys want me to find an ending with
this let me know cuz this is interesting
this is like I love this whole mod I
didn't know this mod was so involved in
replacing everything with ponies ponies
ponies everywhere friendship is magic
I'm embracing the pony side let it be
coming Brody
brohoof red no no okay alright so let me
know if you wanna see the rest of this
cuz this is weird but anyway so thank
you all so much for watching click the
interface of more videos I've done and
as always I'll see you in the next video
[Music]
bud